[Music]
what drives someone to kill in cold
blood what goes through the murderers
mind and what kind of a society breeds
such people over 150 years ago Fyodor
Mikhailovich Dostoevsky took these
questions up in what would become one of
the best-known works of Russian
literature crime and punishment first
serialized in a literary magazine in
1866 the novel tells the story of rodion
romanovitch raskolnikov a young law
student in saint-petersburg Raskolnikov
lives in abject poverty and at the start
of the story has run out of funds to
continue his studies letters from his
rural home only add to his distress when
he realizes how much his mother and
sister have sacrificed for his success
increasingly desperate after selling the
last of his valuables to an elderly
pawnbroker he resolves on a plan to
murder and rob her but the impact of
carrying out this unthinkable act proves
to be more than he was prepared for
though the novel is sometimes cited as
one of the first psychological thrillers
its scope reaches far beyond
Raskolnikov's inner turmoil from dank
taverns to dilapidated apartments and
claustrophobic police stations the
underbelly of 19th century st.
Petersburg is brought to life by
Dostoyevsky searing prose we're
introduced to characters such as
Marmeladov a miserable former official
who has drank his family into ruin and a
fatigue I love an unhinged and lecherous
nobleman as Raskolnikov zone family
arrives in town their moral innocence
stands in stark contrast to the
depravity of those around them even as
their faiths grow increasingly
intertwined this bleak portrait of
Russian society reflects the author's
own complex life experiences and
evolving ideas as a young writer who
left behind a promising military career
Fyodor had been attracted to ideas of
socialism and
and joined a circle of intellectuals to
discuss radical texts banned by the
imperial government upon exposure
members in this group including
Dostoyevsky were arrested many were
sentenced to death only to be subjected
to a mock execution and last-minute
pardon from the Tsar
Dostoevsky spent the next four years in
a Siberian labor camp before being
released in 1854 the experience left him
with a far more pessimistic view of
social reform and his focus shifted
towards spiritual concerns in the 1864
novella notes from underground he
expounded on his belief that utopian
western philosophies could never satisfy
the contradictory yearnings of the human
soul crime and punishment was conceived
and completed the following year picking
up on many of the same themes in many
ways the novel follows a common
narrative thread where a promising youth
is seduced and corrupted by the dangers
of urban life but it's social critique
cuts far deeper Raskolnikov rationalizes
that his own advancement at the cost of
the exploitative pawnbrokers death would
be a net benefit to society
in doing so he echoes the doctrines of
egoism and utilitarianism embraced by
many of Dostoyevsky's contemporary
intellectuals and in believing that his
intelligence allows him to transcend
moral taboos Raskolnikov cuts himself
off from his own humanity yet although
the book is deeply concerned with
morality crime and punishment never
comes across as merely moralizing with
each character given their own
distinctive and convincing voice one of
the most remarkable things about crime
and punishment is its ability to thrill
despite the details of the central
murder being revealed in the first act
Raskolnikov's crime is clear but it's
only through dust IFC's gripping account
of the ensuing social and psychological
turmoil that we learn the true nature of
his punishment and the possibility of
redemption
you can download a free audio version of
crime and punishment from audible.com
slash Ted - Edie
Anthony heald's gripping narration
animates each character with delightful
precision support Ted adds nonprofit
mission as you sink deeper and deeper
into Dostoevsky's moral quagmire
[Music]